[Music]
so where I grew up we were taught to
count seconds one Mississippi two
Mississippi now I can't speak to in
Canada what do they do
oh you do that okay so what I want to do
this morning is teach you another way to
count which is the rate at which stars
explode in the universe
which is one supernova two supernova
here we go one supernova two supernova
so that's what's happening in the
universe roughly every second there is a
star that explodes in our galaxy it
happens only once every 100 years you
can do the math as to how many galaxies
that means there are out there it's
about a billion and as a theoretical
physicist
of course I'm severely disappointed that
the observers are not finding all of
them however they are improving and what
I'm going to talk about today is a
little bit of what's been happening in
the observational world of finding these
stars but also I'm going to speak about
what these are I'm gonna focus on stars
that are more massive than the Sun
things that are roughly ten to ten times
the mass of the Sun or larger because
those are the ones that really make a
lot of the elements that are presently
composed of your body or we or we're
even in the coffee that by now the
caffeine should have sunk in so keep
that in mind so we want to find one per
second so I started my career studying a
neutron star is very dense objects that
Vicki's going to talk about but because
of my involvement with see far I got
very distracted and that distraction
started with one of the first surveys
that really started to have impact on
the field as the community grew and its
ability to detect distant supernovae and
that was the project called the
supernova legacy survey that was carried
out
the Canada France Hawaii telescope this
survey really did find many supernovae
of course not
one per second however it did start the
field in a different mode of being able
to serve a large parts of the sky and
find supernovae shall we say at will at
a rate that allowed for the observers to
study them in detail and so this was the
survey that as I became exposed to it
realized that not only are they finding
many of them but for theorists like
myself I'm much more interested in the
odd supernovae those that are new for us
the rare events I'm not going to talk
about the rare events though many of
those rare events we think are tied to
things that make these compact objects
called magnets ours but I think in a
brief talk that's probably a little bit
too much to hope for so of course the
way you find supernovae is you look for
an arrow in the sky and the arrow always
points to where the event is so it's
quite easy I mean I really should become
an observer it's much much easier so
here's an example of an arrow in the sky
so this is a Hubble image don't ask me
which galaxy it is it doesn't matter but
this is a galaxy much like the Milky
Way's you can tell of course the so it's
a spiral galaxy here's where a pre-image
where there was no supernovae and then
of course when the supernova was
discovered it's here it's a little
difficult to tell in this image is
actually how bright that supernova is
compared to the whole galaxy I'll just
tell you that that typical supernova
could get as bright is about 10% of all
the light in the galaxy so of course to
find them in nearby galaxies they don't
need to be that bright they just need to
be at the arrow tip but in distant
galaxies where as the galaxy gets
further and further away it's occupying
a smaller fraction of the sky and
becoming more like a small blob to
detect these it's it's even harder and
so let me just show you another example
again follow the arrow so this is a
super novae that was found in 2013
supernovae are named by the year they're
found and then as in much of astronomy
we have very arcane ways of naming them
the first one we call big a so 2013 big
a and then Big B what do you think we do
next C what are you doing to get to Z
yeah I forget what they do but they
change it all the time
there's a famous variable star naming
scenario which is even worse than that
but this is this is the astronomers
attempt to keep theorists out because
there's no way I can track what it is
but the excitement here is that you can
see this is a Sloan Digital Sky image of
a galaxy that was prior to the event
that was just sitting shall we say in
the archive and then of course what was
found by looking from one night to the
other was a very bright object and you
could see in this case it's a little
more evident I think that it's
approaching the brightness if you add up
all these brightness of all this whole
galaxy so you find supernovae now by
just looking at large patches of the sky
and the and subtracting the image from
tonight from the image from when you
last observed and this what we call
difference imaging was really the
ability to do that and mass was both
because of C CDs which are becoming less
expensive because all of you have them
in your iPhones and the ability to do
the computing which allows for the
observers to actually do the image
subtraction real time you'd like to find
these events as soon as possible so that
you can follow them up with a much
larger telescope and get much more
detailed information so that's the field
it is I mean it's a pun but the field is
exploding and what I want to talk about
is what are we observing what are these
stars so I want to slow down a little
bit now and give you a very brief course
in stellar structure and evolution when
I teach it at Santa Barbara it's
referred to as stars with Lars
you're gonna get the two-minute version
so the Sun is hot at the center this is
not the Sun but let me do the Sun let's
start with the easy case the Sun is hot
at the center because it needs to be to
hold itself up against gravity so that's
what sets the temperature at the center
of the Sun it's about 10 million Kelvin
in the unit's we like to use as
physicists it's set it's hot at the
centre it's cold at the edge so all of
you know what happens especially because
you live in Canada you think you're
heating your home of course you're not
you're really heating the exterior right
you're setting up a temperature gradient
so it's hot inside and cold outside and
heat is leaving your house the higher
you set the temperature so you're not
heating your home stars are much the
same they're hot at the center and cold
of the surface and so heat is leaving
and the question then is what's the
source of that energy as it leaves well
the source of that energy for most stars
the for all stars alternates between
gravity slight slight slight very slight
in fall upon itself until it gets hot
enough that fusion reactions can start
and those fusion reactions become the
energy source for a long period of time
so the Sun is presently burning hydrogen
to helium that's about halfway done so
you've got about five billion years
before anything like what he may have
been concerned about won't become a
black hole and these fusion reactions
just proceed in massive stars if I now
show you something like a 10 10 or a 15
a star that's 15 times the mass of the
Sun these precede all the way up to make
elements that are heavier and heavier
and heavier until you get to the most
heavy element that gives you energy from
fusion and that's iron and so in this
case the way this star looks at the end
of its life is a ball of iron which is
about a little bit more than the mass of
the Sun and then shells silicon oxygen
carbon helium and material at the
outside edge which actually has not gone
undergone any fusion it's just sitting
there
providing pressure so what happens to
these stars is when you get this much
mass there's no more fusion it collapses
and this collapse an explosion leads to
the creation of all these elements all
of these elements are sent out
it's far far away and become you so
here's carbon an element you probably
like oxygen you're presently breathing
nitrogen is on on here and of course
most of the helium so the big bang makes
very little big bang just makes hydrogen
helium trace of lithium all the other
elements in the periodic table which
i've just flashed up for you here are
made in either this large stars from
this website these are basically the
core collapse supernovae so you can see
carbon nitrogen oxygen everything
basically up to iron and then I'm not
going to talk about because there's
there's well and the amount of time I
have you don't want me to explain the
origin of every element in the periodic
table but the point is that's where
they're being made are in these stars
that explode so if I go back and I just
give you a sense for what's happening
this iron ball collapses at the center
that happens in a time scale of about
one second the collapse is communicated
to the outside of the star from a bounce
that sends a shockwave through the star
that shockwave takes about a day to get
to the surface so if you're at the
surface of the star the first thing you
would feel physically is a shock wave
that goes through you sends you out at
about ten to twenty thousand kilometers
per second moving outwards that
expanding envelope of this whole
material is what provides the bright
event we see as that gas of radiation
and material expands out we see it and
we'll see it for typically 30 days to
maybe even a hundred days quite often if
you wait now a thousand years all of
that ejecta what we called the ejecta
all of that material that was in the
star is now sent out this is the Crab
Nebula is sent out far far away
this is typically this is roughly ten
light years for what I'm going to do
today there's an object left at the
center which is what we call a neutron
star that's that iron ball that
collapsed in the case of this one it's
spinning at 33 milliseconds and a
magnetic field and units that you
probably don't use 10 to the 12 Gauss it
really doesn't have much me
it's a very high magnetic field and this
nebular material is all of that stuff
that was made in the star it's going
back out into the interstellar medium to
be recycled to make new stars new
planets now the last thing I want to
briefly talk about before I talk about
an upcoming survey is that these
supernovae not only spew material out
into their local gas but they also add
up over time to expel gas from galaxies
themselves so this is actually an image
of a galaxy showing material that's
leaving most likely being driven by the
accumulation of a lot of energy from all
these explosions
so not only are supernova important for
understanding how elements are made
they're also very important for
understanding galaxies and how galaxies
evolved with time so just to wrap up I
want to talk briefly about a facility
that's coming online right now again my
friends the observers keep trying they
want to get one a second they're not
there yet but this is a facility that's
coming online at Palomar this is not
Palomar in California it's the fabled
200-inch the 48 inch telescope over here
is the one that did the Palomar plates
which were physically this big which
were the patrol plates for the sky and
what's happening right now is an upgrade
of the camera and there's another fun
Canadian coincidence here which is the
first survey that was done here the
Palomar transient factory used an
original camera from the CFE from CF HT
that was as they say sitting on the
shelf so we got a good sale that only
was able to cover this much of the area
of the camera and now with the new
facility and of course more money
there's now a camera that is filling the
whole plane and this is what it looks
like it exists it's actually on the
telescope it has 600 megapixels which I
know doesn't sound like very much
anymore I don't know what's in your
camera these days but these are really
expensive pixels
you have the cheap pixels and this
survey is going to be able basically to
do the whole sky every night if one
chooses to or search for objects that
change rapidly
you can look even in the same night so
just with that large piece of hardware
in front of you I'm going to stop thank
you very much
[Applause]